many centuries before anybody invented
GDP what was Society like it behaved
exactly as one would expect a society
with very very limited wealth and a very
limited number of people who controlled
the wealth Kings and Aristocrats with a
few others they didn't need to know GDP
they knew they wanted everything 80 to
90% of the population lived on the
margin of survival all their Surplus was
extracted by the top that was the
ultimate zeram society and it became
maximally unequal so my concern when we
go to our new Zero Sum society and I
think we've been moving towards it over
the last 30 or 40 years it becomes
increasingly unequal because that's what
human beings
do